ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Hi, everyone.
We're here at Devoxx
2014, and I'm here
with Cyril Mottier,
who's a Google Developer
expert in Android.
And we're going to
talk specifically
today about Android Wear,
because he is actually
giving a talk about Android
Wear at this conference.
Welcome.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Welcome.
Thank you.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So Android,
from the very beginning, has
had different form factors
and has, from day one, assumed
that people would produce
phones and eventually tablets
of different forms and shapes,
and developers had
to deal with that.
Now we have Android
Wear, which obviously
is a whole lot less real estate,
but it's probably not just
a smaller form factor.
Tell us about how
it changes things
from a developer perspective.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Well,
yes, as you said,
Android Wear is not
just a tiny Android.
Actually, it's a tweaked Android
that is made for wearables.
And by tweaked, I mean that they
completely reinvented the way
that you interact
with the device.
This is done mostly by creating
a new UI, a new user interface,
where the paradigm is completely
different, because you
don't have a grid
of apps anymore.
You have a principle
of cards, and each card
is actually an information
from one application
that you can swipe or
have more info about.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Right.
So I think that's really
key to understand,
that people shouldn't
be just trying
to shrink down an application.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Exactly.
So you have to think
completely differently.
And this is done,
basically, by starting
a completely new design process.
So drop everything that
you've done for the phones
and tablets, and start thinking
about something completely new
for a small form factor.
And you also said about
shapes and stuff like that.
Actually, there
is something which
is quite funny,
because we've always
been prepared, as
Android developers,
about different form
factors, but they were always
square or actually
a rectangle screen.
And now we have round screens,
which is completely new to us,
but the good thing is it's
nice to see that Android adapts
itself quite correctly
to that kind of screen.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
So actually, I think what's
important is to find a good use
case for the wearable.
We're not about trying to
take any and every application
and take it running there.
So the first obvious
use case for which
I understand you
don't have much to do
is notifications in general.
So a wearable, or
Android Wear, is
paired with a phone or a
tablet, so any notification
you get on that device
will also be mirrored,
and the developer doesn't
need to do anything for that.
Is that correct?
CYRIL MOTTIER: Yeah.
We're working out of a box.
Well, it's a spoiler
about my conference
that I will do tomorrow,
but basically, there
are three main principles
on Android Wear, which
is that your application
needs to be glance-able,
it needs to be
contextual, and it
needs to require low
interaction or no interaction.
And when you think
about those principles,
actually, the only thing
on the current Android,
on phones and tablets,
that fits today's principle
are notifications.
So out of the box,
Android Wear is
displaying all of the
notifications that are actually
displayed on the
phones and tablets.
And those notifications
are synced.
So when you swipe away some
notification on the wearable,
they are also swiped from
the phones, and vice versa.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
That's probably very good.
In terms of using the
Notification API from Android,
is there anything
special you need to do,
so it looks good on
the wearable as well?
CYRIL MOTTIER: Well,
as I said, by default,
it works, but it's
not quite fancy.
So you can tweak
the notification
by using some wearable
extender classes, which
are provided as part
of the support library.
By doing that, you can have
access to some new notification
features that are only
available to wearables, such
as you can change
the background,
you can have some
principle of tags or pages
that are quite nice
if you want to--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Group things together.
CYRIL MOTTIER: --split the
information in several cards.
Yeah.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So
eventually, you get to a point
where this is not enough.
You want to get to custom UIs.
You want to build an app that
actually runs on the Android
system you have on your wrist.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Yes.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So that
involves building a full
new app, which eventually
is an APK, which needs to
make its way to the wearable.
So take us through how hard it
is, what it takes to actually--
what kind of APIs do
you have available?
What can you do?
And maybe the workflow.
CYRIL MOTTIER: When you
start with notification,
you have to go through
the custom APK path.
What most people don't know
about that is that actually,
Android Wear is just Android.
At the time we're
talking, it's KitKat.
So what you're doing
for tablets is radically
the same as what you
can do on wearables.
So you have access to the
exact same set of APIs,
except some packages like USB.
You don't have access
to USB, WebKit,
because it makes no
sense on a wearable.
But when you're creating an
application on Android Wear,
from the technical
point of view,
it's exactly the
same as what you
can do on phones and tablets.
What you really
have to keep in mind
is that it's different from
the UX and UI point of view.
This is the only difference
between Android Wear
and Android [INAUDIBLE].
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
OK, I have another difference.
The wearable is not
really connected.
Or it's connected to the
phones, so there's the data--
CYRIL MOTTIER: Not yet, but
maybe it will in the future.
And that's a good
point of using Android
in Android Wear, because
actually, Android
is future-proof.
I don't know when the
technology will evolve
and when wearables will
have access to the network.
Then it will already be ready.
We will have almost nothing to
do, because it's just Android.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Right.
So roll back to today, to
what we have and developers
have today.
They need to use the data
layer APIs to exchange data
and access the
internet, for example.
So how does that work?
The watch cannot make a call
to the internet directly.
It goes through the phone
for anything it has to do.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Yeah.
So nowadays, what we
have is a wearable
that is connected to the phone.
Both phones and
wearables are considered
as nodes in a network.
And because the phone has more
capabilities than the wearable,
it acts like a sever
to the wearable.
So whenever you
want to have access
to some data on
the internet, you
have to make the wearable
connect to the phone
to send and ask for
information to the phone.
And then the phone will ask to
the network, so for instance,
server on your back end.
All of that is done thanks to
an API that is called Data API.
But actually, there
is two other APIs.
But most of the time,
you are using Data APIs,
because it's an API that syncs
some data between the phone
and the wearable automatically
thanks to Google Play Services.
This runs on top of
Google Play Services.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE:
That's a very good point.
Google Play Services plays
this really critical role
and embeds most of the
magic that happens.
CYRIL MOTTIER: It can
be updated automatically
without having to wait
for a system update, which
is quite nice, because if
there are some fixes to do,
Google can push
that automatically
without asking carriers.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So that
was a quick, abstract
view of everything,
but you have been doing
some really concrete work
on an application,
actually, shipping it,
and having people use it.
Tell us about that experience.
What is it, and what does it do,
and maybe some lessons learned.
CYRIL MOTTIER: I've been
working on an application called
Capitaine Train, which
is a company that
sells train tickets.
But what we want to do is
not just sell train tickets.
What we want to do is
to revolutionize the way
that people
experience the train.
And that means that we
also want to improve
the overall experience
in the train.
One of the things that
we have to do in France
is to make the train agent,
train controller check
a barcode, because this barcode
contains your actual ticket.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Your e-ticket, yeah.
CYRIL MOTTIER: So
because of that,
we already had a
phone application
that was displaying the barcode.
It was nice.
But when Android
was released, I was
like, we need to do
that on the wearable,
because it's even more
usable and easy to do.
You don't have to get your phone
out of your pocket or the bag.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Unlock it.
CYRIL MOTTIER: You just
have to look at your wrist,
and present your wrist to the
train agent, and that's it.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE: Yeah.
You get the notification, you
know, where you're sitting.
And then when the
controller shows up--
CYRIL MOTTIER: There
is actually two parts--
the part prior to the trip and
then the part during the trip.
So yeah, you're right.
There is also the
part prior to the trip
where you can have access
to all of the information,
such as your carriage,
your seat, and stuff
like that, what time
the train is leaving.
And then you have
the barcode that you
can present during the trip.
So at the beginning when
I wanted to do that,
I wanted to stay to the
line and use notifications.
But actually, we
have one big problem
with a barcode like that is that
we need to keep the screen on,
because you don't
want the wearable
to turn off while you're
presenting the barcode.
And we also need to--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: And it
needs to be full
brightness, too.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Yeah,
full brightness.
Because of that, we have to go
through the system APK path.
Developing for Android Wear was
quite nice, quite challenging,
because as I said, it's very
similar to what we can do on--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
It's new.
It has rough edges.
It's got to have them.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Of course.
It's Android.
It's not that new,
but actually, what's
new was the communication
between the phone
and the wearable.
And I spent quite
a lot of time--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Understanding exactly what
was going on.
CYRIL MOTTIER: --understanding
exactly what it does.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Maybe
a little bit of magic going on.
CYRIL MOTTIER: I think maybe
the problem is I always
try to deep-dive
into things and try
to understand
exactly how it works.
Maybe it's OK for people that
just want to do something
and don't care
about how it works.
So basically, this
application is automatically
displaying the notification
when it's important to the user.
What we wanted to do
is something that--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
It's contextual, really.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Yeah.
It's contextual.
We didn't want to have
an application kit
that you have to start when
you're in the railway station.
So it's automatic.
It works like magic, and
this is what Android Wear is.
It's just displaying
just the right info
at just the right time.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Right.
It seems to fit very well
with what wearables should be.
And that has been out.
People have been using it.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Yes.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Some good or bad feedback?
People actually using it.
That in itself is a
good feedback, I guess.
CYRIL MOTTIER:
Well, there is not
a lot of people
having an Android Wear
device on their wrist.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE:
It's still pretty new.
CYRIL MOTTIER: But the people
having an Android Wear device
are amazed, because it's--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
It's this magical moment.
CYRIL MOTTIER:
--quite geeky for now,
but it's magical, because it
just shows at the right moment,
and you can present
that to the train agent.
I think the most amazed people
were actually the train agents,
because they were
like, what is that?
They were so proud to
scan my wrist like that.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: And I'm
pretty sure you
had some fun, too,
doing that when it
was not even released
and they were the first ones.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Yeah, especially
during the beta phase,
because I was the only one
having this application.
And the controller-- well,
I have never seen that.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE: It
was pretty easy for them, too,
right?
They too don't have to wait
for somebody to pull out.
So it's quicker and
faster for them as well.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Exactly.
So it just works.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So I
guess we had a quick tour here.
Maybe I have one
last, final question.
What kind of watch do you wear?
CYRIL MOTTIER: So
I have the LG one.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
Tell me more about why you have
this one more than another one.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Well, I actually
have the Samsung one and also
the Moto 360, but I decided
to switch back to the LG one
after using the Moto
360 for three weeks,
because I think the
Moto 360 is nice.
It's good-looking.
It's better than a
square screen like that.
But I think it's too big.
And the second problem I have
with that is that I'm a runner.
And when I run with a leather
bracelet, I sweat a lot,
and I don't like to have
the wet bracelet like that.
And because this
one is in plastic,
I don't have that
kind of problem.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
You can change straps.
CYRIL MOTTIER: I can
change, but actually, I
would like to change
between when I'm at work
and when I'm running.
I would like to have
two different bracelets.
And this is not currently
possible with Android Wear.
I hope it will be in the future.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Well, we already
have different form factors,
different manufactures,
different everything, which is
the idea of having one Android
Wear but different
implementations,
different devices.
CYRIL MOTTIER: Exactly.
I've tested the application, for
instance, on the three devices,
and it was working correctly.
This is where Android excels.
It works everywhere.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Great.
So on that note, I think that's
all the time we have for you.
Thank you, Cyril,
for taking the time.
And go get some Wear apps.
Develop them, use them,
give us some feedback.
Cheers.